[Music]
10 years ago we launched the W madidi
Economic Development strategy this
helped to guide our district through the
post earthquake recovery phase now with
the support of enterprise north canbury
we're refreshing the strategy with a
focus to ensure the district's continued
and sustainable economic growth for the
next 10 years the W Mar Economic
Development strategy will see an
emphasis placed on actions that support
our businesses Industries and wider
economy transition to a low mission and
prosperous future the draft strategy
outlines a vision for the district as a
thriving prosperous and environmentally
responsible economy and one that
underpins our desirable local
lifestyle for more information and to
have your say go to wad. govt.
nzl talk we'd love to hear from you